[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en train de chauffer j'ai envie je
vous jure que c'est vrai de faire un
combat de mma avant la fin de la saison
vous moi la bonne cause bien sûr mon ami
poteau vous savez c'est cette
association que je vais lancer à partir
de janvier
je vous donnerai la date exacte pour
venir en aide à ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin
et bien sûr tous tous les vénézuéliens
et tous les bénéfices du combat iront
cette association
maman
[Musique]
et vous faites quelque chose de me
regarder ouais ouais c'est pas parce que
je me dis bientôt je pourrai le faire et
il me regardera de chez lui mon chéri
écoute moi bien si je gagne je gagne ta
chemise qui nous la donne tout de suite
si je perds je te le dis je t'envoie
pour un séjour magnifique
[Applaudissements]
quelle émission de merde
tu vas pas dire demain et tout s'arrête
pas là
déjà tu martin guay la journée tu m'a
flingué la nuit la tchéquie j'ai pas
d'emblée à cause de ça public de merde
[Applaudissements]
gagner c'est bon je sais mon sentiment
je craque oui
face à ça c'est abou diab république de
tours 0 0 avec un téléphone différence
sur l'a20 c'est n'importe quoi ce match
est déjà gagné
je suis très contente et gally tu sais
quoi vouloir en tout cas tu toi toi toi
peut-être temps de te regarder le gia
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je préfère des défaites comme les
miennes que des victoires comme etienne
[Applaudissements]
je ne joue plus au ping pong je suis sur
les combats en ce moment je ne joue plus
au ping pong je regarde ma pièce tu
reviens demain vous allez thomas revient
regarde jamais mon portable et je trouve
ça n'à voir si la chick lit ça fait deux
fois de suite me bats j'avoue j'avoue
aujourd'hui je vais le défoncer je me
suis entraîné toute la nuit j'ai pas
dormi de la nuit
je peux vous dire j'ai me s'entraîner
voilà je suis à fond oui et à lui nous
ce soir
merci d'accueillir le champion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plus tôt
m
[Applaudissements]
soit
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent à deux
balles de match pour la personne va pas
trop stressé bonjour tu l'as déjà battue
de munich
elle tombe et c'est une grande gueule
sache que tu auras des victoires
[Applaudissements]
je ne perdrai plus contre dominique
paillé vient d'un problème de luminosité
là j'ai réglé c'est terminé merci on
passe à autre chose aller quand
j'entends cette chanson je ne réponds
plus de rien
[Musique]
le chauffeur
[Applaudissements]
c'était
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]